we all need to plan for the future and
our next guest has a way of putting
money in your pocket and keeping it
there welcome author and long-term care
specialist susan marshall to the show
susan welcome back your book protecting
your future with tax-free income for
lawn care is so
relevant to our viewers well thank you
mercedes it is it's it addresses one of
those top financial concerns people have
and that is how to pay for those
long-term care expenses without going
broke in the process so the book serves
to educate and help answer those
questions yeah i have a copy of it here
how big of a problem is long-term care
it's bigger than what most people
realize consider this we have 8 900 baby
boomers turning 65 every day and as they
age their need for care increases
but what i really want to bring
awareness to is dementia because every
65 seconds someone is being diagnosed
with alzheimer's disease and that's just
one type of dementia now that can not
only affect the person but it really can
impact the family too emotionally
physically financially
so
what can we do
when it comes to dementia i'm excited
because i've been asked to host for the
dementia society of america
workshops they're entitled
seven
action steps to dementia and these will
be all hosted these workshops are
excellent for those who do have the
concern
regarding dementia or how they are going
to pay for those future long-term care
expenses there's the information right
there on your screen about these
workshops with the dates uh the windmill
library conference room and you're going
to have a guest speaker too right
absolutely will we actually it's going
to be exciting it's in two parts kevin
jameson he is the founder of
the dementia society of long-term care
he shares his personal story
and
action steps to do sooner than later and
then i've been asked to speak on the
financial impact of long-term care and
how to manage this type of care but
what's really exciting is that
these vents you know join us just
encourage those viewers to join us yeah
really if this is something that is
affecting you or someone in your family
you're going to get so much great
information there
and people want the book
protecting your future with tax free
long-term care it is excellent if you
want to contact susan d marshall or rsvp
for the events you're actually doing
something really special for our viewers
right now you can call at
most importantly 702-546-8825 just
encourage the viewers to support us by
inviting those who might be concerned
about this join us and learn about this
important information
next 100 people to call will get the
books 100 so make sure you call and
check out those workshops it's going to
be fantastic
las vegas now we'll be